let's say you and your buddy are
thinking about asking a girl to prom but
he's like ah man I want to ask Nicole
and you're like all right man why don't
you go ask her it's like what if she
says no he's like well then you're in
the exact same position you are now
which is you have no prom date you will
also have no prom date but you'll have
experience of asking one girl what
happens when you talk to the next row
you'll probably be a little less nervous
and you probably realize that you'll
survive you will live if you hear a no
and if you ask 100 girls do you think
one of them will say yes to your prom
date probably and in that situation what
are you now better off than you were
before you asked the moral of the story
there is that you lose nothing for no
you only stand something to gain from
yeses and one yes can change your entire
life if you're willing to be rejected
and see the rejections as you learning
meaning you win and see the yeses as you
also winning then you can't lose